foreign
I've been living with this character for
eight years
we laughed cheered cried together
the core pillar of this franchise is
figuring out who you really are and
what's worth fighting for
in Creed Three I wanted to know what a
dinosaur's limits were so to be able to
finally step behind the camera
continue to elevate and evolve this
story it's something I'm externally
grateful for
in my man can I help you you'll remember
me huh damn you as a Storyteller you
really put a piece of yourself into your
films from personal desires and goals to
shortcomings failures mistakes here's
what happened with you too he was like
brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that
Creed Three it's not just your typical
boxing movie we really want to take
advantage of the emotional journey of
the characters and put that into the
ring and have it pay off in a physical
way something is going on with you Emmy
was like family
oh we passed talking then maybe you just
have to find out do what I gotta do some
of my methods you might disagree with me
this is the first sports film to be shot
on IMAX cameras with the IMAX experience
you can take in the environment in a way
that you normally wouldn't
be able to see every beat of sweat every
impact the ripples in the skin the
sounds of the footsteps the punches the
music the lack of sound and really
immerse yourself into the entire world
foreign
everybody has things that they wish they
could have done differently
so to be able to see a character like
Adonis go through some of those things I
hope audiences walk away feeling
inspired and I have the courage to do
something that you normally wouldn't do
[Music]
it I need you to make all your fear
fear let go of whatever was and walk
into what is I want people to walk away
from this movie feeling better than they
did when they walked in I think that's
something that's powerful about Central
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you